[Music]
one of the key desires of love is the
wish to help another person but an
intention doesn't always or
automatically translate into a ready
capacity for true assistance picture a
five-year-old who stumbled into his
parents bedroom and surprised his mother
crying she's normally so strong and
ready with help for him now he longs to
do something to staunch the tears but
he's at sea the sobs might be about the
mortgage a turbulent time at work or an
argument with her partner could all
these art for a child to grasp he
sweetly suggests a glass of water and
pipes out that he might run downstairs
to get a knitted rabbit the impulse to
help floats logically free of any actual
ability to do so two people can long to
be supportive and generous towards one
another and yet lack all the skills to
deliver on their good intentions and
therefore end up feeling isolated
resentful and unloved we cause ourselves
trouble because we're too slow to
recognize an odd largely unmentioned
phenomenon how varied in particular our
notions of help can be we take our own
preferred style of being soothed as the
natural starting point for how to soothe
others but when we're wrong and our
partners original distress is compounded
by their sense of having being ignored
or insulted we take them to be
ungrateful and cruel and vow never to
attempt to be kind again an urgent task
is therefore to try to understand the
particular way in which we and our
partner need love to be delivered in
order to feel that it is real the
mightly types who when we're sad or in
difficulties need first and foremost to
speak what we say may not be entirely
sequential we might go back over things
a few times and omit to cap our stories
with an attendings but that might not
matter because what we want above all
from a partner when we're suffering is
that they sit with us at length and
listen we want them to signal their
engagement with their eyes but not with
their mouths to register our anger
to observe our disappointment and at
most at opportune moments to prompt us
with a go on or a small supportive sound
yet what we absolutely don't want to
answer solutions or analyses for them to
open their wallets to give us a plan or
to rush to fill in our silences we want
them to sit listening because the real
problem we need assistance with isn't so
much the specific issue we're mentioning
the parking ticket the in-laws the
delayed delivery
it's the overarching sense that most
people we encounter can't really be
bothered to take the time to imagine
themselves correctly into our lives
perhaps there was a history to this a
parent's might have been practically
minded busy and successful but somehow
Robert Callison distracted in the way
they saw always in immediately to push
all difficulties out of the way with
logic now we feel how an immediate
solution can be an excuse for not
listening to the problem that's why just
being heard feels like the quintessence
of love we might almost deliberately
take our time go back over points
without partner go back over points our
partner had thought were finished and we
explore a jagged bit of our story what
to believe but because such rehearsals
create the backdrop for the only style
of help we crave and trust receptive
quiet attention then again at another
end of the spectrum love might not feel
real unless it's accompanied by precise
and concrete solutions vague sympathy is
worthless we might want to hear a flow
of ideas as to what we should do next
what sort of strategy we should deploy
whom we might call and how we can get
answers it's all very well for someone
to say they feel our pain we would
prefer a plan love is a sheet of paper
with a list of bullet points in your
partner's handwriting in addition we
might not be averse to evidence that our
partner has spent some money on our
problems time isn't a currency we
respect we might want them to pay for an
accountant or a lawyer or offer an
evening in an expensive restaurant after
an economically fragile childhood to
feel really helped we might long for
evidence of financial outlay we can't be
reassured just by what someone says
we've built up a residual suspicion and
distrust around loan verbal offerings we
remember how nice it was when an elderly
relative unexpectedly gave us a very
well chosen present when we were nine
and in hospital after a bad fall they
never said very much to us perhaps they
were rather shy but this gesture truly
touched us we felt sure of their
kindness as if for the first time when
we learned just how much the present had
cost differently again when we divulge
our Macanese our priority may just be to
hear that everything will eventually be
okay we don't mind a little bit of
exaggeration despair strikes us as cheap
reasons to give up our always of this
for us love is a species of hope all
alternatively it's hope that maybe
enraging what calms us down is a quiet
walk around the prospect of catastrophe
we don't want to be alone in our fears
we long for someone to explore the
grimmest possibilities with bleak
software to mention prison insolvency
front-page headlines and the grave only
when our partner is ready to match our
most forbidding analyses can we be
reassured we're not in the hands of a
callous sentimentalist rather someone
honest enough to see the dangers and to
worry about them as much as we do and
perhaps stick with us while we serve out
the prison sentence a cuddle can sound
to some like a petty response to bad
news but for us it can be the most
reliable evidence of heartfelt love to
help our minds we need someone first to
reassure our bodies to hold us tightly
and quietly while we close our eyes in
pain and surrender to their firm embrace
help in adulthood may for others be
associated with a gift of insight but
for us it is touch that soothes we're
picking up on memories of early
childhood wise parents know that a
distressed child doesn't need a lesson
or a lecture they should be lay down on
the bed held and their head stroked by a
giant soft adult hand the misfortune
lies in how easily we can irritate with
the wrong offer of love and in turn how
quickly we can be offended when our
efforts at
bingo unappreciated recognizing that
there are different styles of help at
least alerts us to the severe risks of
misunderstanding
instead of getting annoyed our lovers
inept and sometimes wildly misdirected
efforts we can grasp perhaps for the
first time the basic truth that these
blundering companions are in fact
attempting to be nice in turn the
clearest clue of the kind of help our
partner wants is the help they offer us
it seems love can't remain at the level
of intentions alone it must involve
constant strenuous efforts to translate
our wishes into interventions truly
aligned with the psychology and history
of another human being
[Music]
you